There can not be peace, without first
a great suffering
The greater the suffering,
the greater the peace
The end you've always feared
is coming
it's coming
and the blood will be on your hands
I prayed to god that it wasn't true
Soloman Lane escaped in Paris
And now the world is at risk
This is the CIA's mission
You use a scalpel,
I prefer a hammer
This is a bad idea
Is it ever a good one? honestly
He's not just some observer
He's an assassin
You go rogue, he's been authorised to hung you down and kill you
That's the job,
no hard feelings
Which way Benji?
Turn left!
what are you waiting for?
I'm jumping out a window
Oh sorry, good luck
When the clock stops,
Ethan Hunt will loose everyone he ever cared about
You don't understand what you're in involved in
You need to walk away
Please don't me go through you
Ethan that's not who we are
Maybe we need to reconsider that
Accept it Ethan,
you've lost this one
what's done is done
What's done is done,
when we say it's done
Showtime
Oh my God